this is not who i normally
am
but this whole crisis thing
has changed me i'm a crisis nurse
hey craig are you going to keep fighting
yes
i was in new york from the time it
started
now i chased the outbreak throughout
america
i have to be on the road pretty much now
15 minutes that was a new record for me
time to get in the car and go
this is a long road
it doesn't matter if you're liberal or
you're conservative
none of that matters to this virus it's
impartial
[Music]
more and more nurses want to speak out
because only we're allowed to see what
goes on inside these hospital walls
second code of the day
this afternoon
and it's probably not going to be the
only one
a traveling crisis nurse pretty much we
are called in last minute
and our page help hospitals in
any area that needs help and is
struggling from
copen 19. we can see where
the next outbreak is happening by the
amount of money that they're paying
every day the rates go up in the states
that are being hit the hardest
we're going to go wherever we're going
to get paid the most because if our
lives are online
we did not become nurses to watch people
die
we became nurses to stop it
it's gonna be a rough night tonight
we're about to lose another one
she's 43
we're in debating one right now
and then we lost two today we appreciate
you
prayers ringo thanks guys
we carry the chance of being infected
and dying every day that we go to work
i worked through the pandemic
[Music]
in new york
and then he came to texas to help
[Music]
i just asked people to please wear your
mask
even with all the precautions
i took
i still get sick
i was in new jersey first and then i was
in new york city
then arizona then victoria texas
and now i'm in different private texas
everything's gonna be okay
everything's gonna work out it's gonna
suck when i get there
how much you wanna bet it's gonna be a
cluster but that's my job
is to help untangle those clusters
so i used to be republican i even voted
for trump
i don't know what i am politically
anymore i just want to keep people alive
that's my only goal
i work six days a week
i work from 7 am to 7 pm
[Music]
the vibe of this city is they don't
really believe this virus
is as big as we say it is or
is important as we say it is things i've
seen
are a lot of cool parties people walk
around up nass at all
no social distance saying
i firmly believe as a christian
that simply wearing a mask and keeping
your distance from others
is loving them
okay time to pray and go to work
i'm seeing overflows of coronavirus
patients into
other force i'm seeing doors and windows
made out of
plastic and plywood in hospitals which
i've never seen before
to fill makeshift coveted infection
spaces
i'm seeing people get really sick
i see people dying
so i've seen a lot of families in this
town
grieving and confused
when i tell them about the virus i even
had a patient
whose last words were i don't have the
virus
and then he died it took about two or
three minutes
before he was gone two or three minutes
when i talk to other nurses about our
mental health
we all agree that we have ptsd
i just can't
a lot of us talk about panic attacks
or nightmares or reliving moments
that we wish we didn't have to vote i
can't wrap my brain around
not being there when my family's dying
and it's
it's tough to hear them saying goodbye
on a
video none of the news is good
so far none of the families are
accepting it's always
well he's a fighter if anybody's gonna
beat it he can my dad can
still hoping that i can make it out
there
i won't put and see my family
that i miss that i miss so much
i spent the they in this room
[Music]
and nobody comes here to sit for you
know the nurses
it's been really tough
so we just got off our shift talking
about a patient that
is actively bleeding and that's led into
conversation about
this disease and how it causes blood
clots when they go into
what's called dic and they start
bleeding out everywhere and we're kind
of worried that that's what's going to
happen to this lady
oh my gosh like why is there so much
what
i don't know she's the i say she's gonna
bleed out
she's a full time
if this happens again i'm not going to
be a nurse anymore i'm not doing this
i'm not dealing with this whatever that
was just in the room with i don't want
that
i don't want to die that way
oh my god it was so bad
[Music]
it was so horrifying to watch
[Music]
i don't know why she was bleeding so
much
i don't want whatever that was i want
everybody to know
how much i hate covid and i hate people
that
think it's a hoax because you're not
here and you're not taking care of these
families
and you're not holding the hand of the
dying and you're not watching
somebody that can't breathe and there's
absolutely nothing you can do
so up yours
if you're one of those just up yours
i am going to get tested tomorrow i have
a really bad headache
i really hope i don't have what i just
saw today
what's going on with you today are you
sick um
i have a headache and fatigue i'm a
complete crisis nurse
i'm not the same person that i used to
be
i miss who i used to be who i used to be
is better than who i am now
i still appreciate my life trust me
and i know we're not promised tomorrow
but how did we get here
how did our country as a whole
get to the place we're in now
uh
you